climate change affects us all but around
the world will disproportionately impact
the lives of people of color
yet climate protests in the uk are seen
as not
racially diverse enough
extinction rebellion has forced the
climate debate with high-profile civil
disobedience resulting
in huge numbers of arrests but the risk
of
charges and fines has deterred some
lower-income protesters
and people of color so we're just going
to go and sit the band
lucy craig now aged 73 was arrested in
one of the first
major xr demonstrations and says she was
unafraid of the repercussions
it was really no skin off my back being
arrested but if you were a young
black male or female i don't think it
would be nearly as easy
you think that being a kind of
middle-class well-off
white woman helped you within the
protest
absolutely everything is fueled by white
privilege
um including activism yeah
yeah for sure however well-meaning
rosemary mallet says tackling climate
change can't just be driven
by white activists the archdeacon of
croydon has established herself
as a leading figure on climate change
within the church of england
trying to give a voice to those who feel
less empowered to bring about
change many black people understand that
if they are arrested
it's going to have a tremendous impact
on their lives
on perhaps their employment and so many
other ways in which they and their
family lives their lives
and she questions whether the climate
movement is at a crossroads
i think there is a need for an evolution
away from
the kind of sharp shocking protest i
think we've we've done it
and i think with any group it needs to
evolve and think about its tactics
in how it wants to change the debate
this group of climate activists who
formed the air pollution group choked up
snapped themselves talking on zoom they
didn't want the death of ella kisi
deborah who died from air pollution in
2013 to be in vain
ella lived by the busy south circular
road in south london
her friend anjali ramon middleton says
all environmental activism in the uk
is seen as a very white activity
it is more difficult to be a climate
activist
if you are a person of color and i think
a lot of this is about the way that
environment and
environmental issues are framed by um
the movement and they're often framed
through a very
um white middle-class perspective
lockdown has brought about an enforced
shutdown of some
forms of climate activism an opportunity
to regroup
or perhaps reboot the movement lisa
holland
sky news